I was supposed to die at that time
anyway if I die now I'll be happy
kill me while I'm still young and still
pretty hello and welcome to Death Note
101 the series that breaks down everyone
and everything in the Death Note world
and today we are going to be taking a
look at the not-so-bright follower of
Kyra the one who did everything she
could for the sake of whom she loved
Misa Amane Misa Amane is a young model
an actress whose personality traits
include mischievousness boldness and
cheerfulness because this she is one of
the only comedic and fun-loving
characters in the entirety of the Death
Note series with the only other person
kind of fulfilling that role being told
her Matsuda however despite this
cheerful nature Misa rather sadly has
one of the darkest backstories of any
character in the series roughly a year
before the events of Death Note Misa
witnessed the murder of her parents
during an armed robbery and while the
culprit was apprehended by the police it
was the justice system that would
ultimately come to fail Misa with her
parents murder trial extending on and on
to the point where it was believed that
he would escape punishment however just
as Misa had lost all hope the murderer
was struck down by the hand of Kira
after which point Misa felt the justice
had finally been delivered Misa greatly
relieved then swiftly became a dedicated
supporter of Kira and the Utopia he
represented which was of world without
crime her primary goal in life then
became to find Kira and to thank him for
what he had done shortly thereafter Misa
went on to start a successful modeling
career
well mostly successful because
unfortunately becoming a public figure
also came with some hazards such as you
know stalkers and one particular stalker
went so far as to confess his feelings
for me so however upon being rejected he
pulled out a knife and made a genuine
attempt to kill her but before he could
make good on his intentions Misa would
be saved as the fan died of a sudden
heart attack in an eerily similar manner
as to how Kira kills his victims however
it was not Kira who was responsible for
saving Lisa's life but another one of
her fans actually said this fan was not
a human but a Shinigami named jealous
who had been obsessively watching Misa
from the Shinigami realm having fallen
in love with her in saving her life
jealous sacrificed his own due to the
innate roles of Shinigami existence as
their purpose is to take life to extend
their own rather than to extend the life
of others and after being reduced to
dust jealous as Death Note was inherited
by the Shinigami RAM who delivered it to
Misa in the human realm and became her
sort of Shinigami can
in much the same way that Reeve did to
light unlike light Enrico ever Misa and
REM developed an actual relationship
becoming strong friends and greatly
enjoying each other's company Nisa would
speak to REM all the time in Oscar
various questions which REM would answer
as best she could even when it pertained
to sensitive Shinigami information REM
even goes so far as to give me sir
advice and actively help her
unlike Rio who didn't care for light
whatsoever he just wanted to observe and
be entertained with that said as the
series progresses Lisa's relationship
with REM is entirely overshadowed by her
obsession with light to the point where
even after REM comes to sacrifice
herself to save Misa Misa seems pretty
much unaffected by this action instead
simply blinded by her happiness to
continue being with light in any case
we're getting ahead of ourselves
so after learning of the Shinigami realm
and the Death Note Misa was now well
aware of how Kira conducted his killings
and vowed to use her newfound power to
help him and to this end Misa even made
a deal with Bream to obtain Shinigami
eyes which allow they use it to see
people's names and lifespans simply by
looking at them although in order to
make the deal Misa had to give REM half
of her remaining lifespan then in order
to contact here Misa concocts a plan to
send a series of video tapes to the
Sakura TV station in which she claims to
be Kira and even provides evidence to
back it up for example on the first tape
Misa predicts the death of two criminals
and then proceeds to use her Death Note
to kill them at the appointed time
nieces approached during this time also
highlighted the fact that she has filed
a strict about who she kills as opposed
to light at least initially anyway which
was shown when Misa was willing to kill
police officers for the sake of her
goals a factor that immediately tip Dell
off to the idea that they were not
dealing with the original Kira who had
no desire to kill innocence and would
lead to Misa being dubbed the second
Kira with that said mrs. Bhatt worked
out in her favor as she was able to
communicate a coded message to light
resulting in their eventual meeting
during said meeting Lisa fell in love
with light instantly and offered herself
to be used in his endeavor to craft to
utopia and even our slide to make her
his girlfriend to a chair strategically
declined but offered to play the part in
public in order to facilitate the new
partnership of worlds domination this
rejection does not deter me see in the
slightest sir who said that she would
work hard to make light love her and
from here on out light would be niece's
only focus of attention Misa would go on
to confess her love to light multiple
times during series but at no point does
he seem to care for her in the same way
or arguably Bertil despite this Misa
continue to follow light everywhere and
obey every order given to this
Mesa even did the unthinkable and made
the shinigami ideal once more this time
with Rio
after she had lost her initialize having
her lifespan again and effectively
leaving her with only a quarter of the
life she had left remaining but despite
all of this devotion my it was often
extremely agitated by Mises antics which
can be explained by her overactive
nature and simple lack of intelligence
which is seen in her official statistics
having only been granted a three out of
ten in the error of knowledge thus
making her the least intelligent
character in the entire series but to be
fair Mesa could probably be best
described as an average human in a
series populated with geniuses so we're
not going to hold that against her
furthermore she more than makes up for
her lack of knowledge with her social
skills and general charm for which means
has scored a perfect 10 out of 10 in
both areas as a result Mesa is generally
quite warm and kind towards any new
person she meets and is very quick to
change her mind about anybody she
dislikes if they start acting even
remotely nice towards her nearly real
exception to this are the other women in
lights life toward su Mesa shows an
incredible degree of jealousy and often
makes comments to do with killing them
herself with the Death Note following
Elle's death and the time-skip mises
role in the story becomes significantly
reduced although she does develop a
conflict with lights new girlfriend
Kiyomi Takada to top it all off this is
after she is forced to relinquish her
ownership of the Death Note once more
after light is put under surveillance by
the SPK led by one of Elle's successes
which effectively ended Lisa's active
role in the story then when light is
eventually defeated and killed Mesa is
shown standing on a rooftop implying
that she possibly means to commit
suicide after having heard that the love
of her life had passed away however her
eventual fate is never shown not in the
actual series anyway however according
to her profile in chapter 110 how to
read she passed away roughly a year
after light with the author speculating
that she fell into despair and committed
suicide just for one final kick in the
gut Mises date of death is February 14th
meaning that she died on Valentine's Day
some more fun facts about Mesa Mesa
surname mamani literally translates to
heavenly sound or the sound of rain the
series illustrators Takeshi Obata has
stated that Mesa was the hardest
character to design in the entire series
this was due to her character needing to
be capable of conveying both silly and
serious expressions which required a
versatile character design mises
character was planned to be the second
Kira even before Death Note began
serialization this was because the
makers of Death Note did not want the
story to be solely about male characters
and they wanted a quote-unquote cute
male in the novel el changed the world
Mesa actually lives after light's defeat
and works as a singer and in this story
that exists strictly in an alternate
continuity Mises past has also explored
a bit more in depth through the addition
of her childhood friend Marky and
finally a truly useless fact in the
Death Note anime when the audience hears
Mises thoughts her hair turns blue
except in episodes 21 and 22 where it
remains yellow for some reason but that
pretty much does it for Misa Amane if
you enjoyed this video and the content
this channel produced in general then
please do consider donating to the New
World review patreon because the support
of all of you amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan ray takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
who what or where you'd like to see
featured in the next deathnote 101
[Music]
so as a professional fashionista Mesa
actually thought quite long and hard
about her disguise for this particular
scene before settling on the black bob
cut you may be surprised to learn that
other options included red mesa purple
mesa teo mesa rainbow mesa
elvis Mesa Vegeta Mesa and even Gandalf
Mesa and yet she went with the black bob
cut her
no wonder like questions or judgment